when you were going through Times Square
didn't you did you meet a beetlejuice
yeah this is tremendous what happened
was it was I think was the last shot of
the film and we're shooting you know
well into the morning and uh one of the
guys on the crew Mike says there's a guy
standing there got standing there like
this you know really bored he who had
been on his way somewhere to his job or
home from his job to see his girlfriend
or someone or something do something I
don't know what it was the big guy
grabbed him brought him over he said
there's a guy standing there and the
crew guy says sure he rolls the sleeve
up like this on flesh and unbelievably
well detailed and really beautiful
tattoo of beetlejuice I started I think
we've got a picture I think somebody
told ya there's yeah yeah look how good
that it's that it's amazing isn't it
it's extraordinary and I go oh holy moly
this is extraordinary I'm looking at it
I'm going what I'm asking all these
questions and you just stand there
looking at that I finished he says
you've done those asleep down there goes
up and gets back up in his viking keeps
on going you never put the two together
he never went oh my god there you know
here you are never anything like you did
three blocks down the coke
talking of tattoos is it true Jamie
Oliver you are thinking of getting a
tattoo
whether I'm 40 next year so I thought
that it might be a good idea did you say
80 it's a good idea imagine no I was
just you know midlife crisis type thing
really you know we're not we were
talking about it on a radio show and
they ended up turning into a competition
to think of Jamie Oliver's tattoo you
know what should he have cuz I wasn't
sure what I should have and you know as
I sort of put it somewhere so my dad
wouldn't find out because he wouldn't
like it if I had a tattoo doesn't
believe in that and so they did a
company you're not gonna have to worry
about your dad well you know exactly
that's why eighties the ideal age to get
it and your father wants hey by the way
you know where the skin's going to go by
that time yes that's great they came out
all these ideas and at one of them that
made me laugh a lot was something yes
you should get a tattoo on your penis
with the word el dente on it
you imagine if you had a boyfriend with
that and they'd be like yes give me a
couple of minutes and never get old but
now I haven't done that just say you
know Victoria would if you had wild
afternoon when you went to get a tattoo
no not a middle-aged lady thing to do is
it really he's 40 considered that well
partly I think you know it's very
shallow and that people should really
get in touch with our interior selves
and yeah I'd love to have some friends
you know and they'd hit middle age they
just go crackers and suddenly you know
these women who've just spent years just
sitting on a sofa with big fat arms
brushing monstermunch off their fleece
zipping themselves into suede jeggings
and this is my time Derek
[Applause]
[Music]
moved all the gate was this
[Applause]